um
okay it's half past are you okay for us
to start sonia
um simon i was indicating um i'm sorry
will you start can i just ask for some
clarification
yeah yeah you just mentioned that you
take
um questions in order which i obviously
appreciate but the customer has been in
the past when we've been in the chamber
for visiting members to be
asked to speak first um so
that is still is still going to be
history oh
oh yes yes the visiting members will
will speak first
um prior to the the formal debate
uh starting sometimes we change
we change the order around in the actual
debate just to help the
the flow right
excuse me it's councillor laurie short
i've just rung leslie butcher she can't
make it
she does apologize okay thank you very
much then
okay let's welcome
to the rochford district council's
remote development
control meeting and welcome to
everyone that is uh that is joining us
on the 27th of august 2020
um our first item is apologies for
absence and as we've heard they've just
been received from
councillor butcher non-members attending
we have for councillor eaves we have
council mrs mason
for councillor merrick we have
councillor gooding and for councillor
mrs weston we have councillor steptoe
in addition i see that visiting members
we have
councillor wootton and councillor mr hoy
um that takes us swiftly on to item four
a slight
correction on the agenda it's the minute
sorry chairman you've
also got uh arthur williams he's on the
committee
minutes of the meeting that were held on
the 25th of june 2020
are you happy for me to sign those in
due course as a correct
and accurate record of that meeting
agreed
agreed okay take that
uh is unanimous um right
item five is declarations of
interest i will as a matter of course
on item number
seven as a rochford district council
application just uh note
or all of our um interests on that just
for the record as a formality
so if i can go through first
um counselor gudding first place
yes can i declare some non-cunary
interests in the uh little stanbridge
1900 96926
okay uh and the basis that interest as a
parish councillor thank you
thank you councillor steptoe please
yes thank you chairman with regards to
the ashland and
proposal i also declare myself as a
count the county councillor
thank you councillor mr shaw
thank you item eight uh stanbridge
i am the world cup one of the war
councillors thank you thank you that's
non-pecuniary interest sorry
okay councillor mr hoy
uh thank you chairman it's it's not a
true declaration of interest but for the
for the appearance of transparency i
think it's advisable that i
declare that i do eat and drink in the
anchor 284 free road quite frequently
thank you canceler mr shaw
um non-pecuniary interest item eight
i'm the chairman of stanbridge parish
council
but i do not take part in any of the
development uh that meetings
thank you and the final one counselor
yanu
chairman i would like to declare a
non-proper interest on item a1
uh as the uh the applicant
is my landlord as well as
uh on on the parish council and ward
councillor
uh so what what does that mean cancer
arno
does that mean that you're intending to
take part in the debate or
no i won't be taking part in the debate
as advised by the monitoring officer
but i am allowed to act since i've
called it in
to uh state my my case
yeah okay yeah that's fine then thank
you um
councillor wilson you've been away and
come back did you have any interest to
declare
uh yes chairman uh item six i've been a
patron at the establishment
on many occasions and i'll be there on
monday whatever the tonight's decision
is
okay thank you very much then
that clears up the declaration so we
move on to
item six which is
284 ferry road home bridge
it's extension and refurbishment of
existing building
and various other items i think katie
rogers is going to present
to us on this one please okay thank you
um i presume you can hear me okay i
think yeah um i'm gonna share my screen
with you
so hopefully what you can see on the
screen is the location plan
so members this application seeks
extension and alteration of the anchor
a public house restaurant the site is
located towards the northern end of
ferry road
adjacent to the river crouch the
existing public house occupies a central
position on the site which is edged red
on the screen
i'll take you to an extract
um of the existing and proposed site
plans
and i've put these side by side as this
gives a clear illustration of the
development proposed
you'll note that the rear wall so this
on the
right hand left hand side of your screen
you'll see the existing site layout plan
and on the right hand side the proposed
so the rear wall which is shown by my
cursor
here remains consistent
but changes to the western northern and
eastern sides are proposed
to the west here hopefully you can see
my cursor pointing at that
part to the west um the existing
entrance would be removed
to the north the existing single-story
front extension will be removed
the extension proposed is to the east so
on this proposed plan there my curse is
pointing at the proposed
eastern extension and you'll note the
three ridge lines
orientated in the north-south direction
so one there
two there and three there on the eastern
extension
the front wall of the east extension
would be staggered rather than a single
flush front wall
a terrace is proposed but it would wrap
around the front and side of the
building
and it's shown in the sort of brighter
blue color and my cursor is just
indicating that there
the remainder of the site to the north
where my cursor is
and to the side here would remain
grasped
i'll take you now to the existing and
proposed
elevations again i've shown these side
by side for ease of comparison
so on the right hand side as you look at
the screen you've got the proposed
elevations
and the corresponding existing
elevations
on the left-hand side of the screen
members will note the single story flat
roof front projection
on the existing as shown by the cursor
here is to be removed
and the front wall of the existing
building would be pulled back to this
point here
where there's a shallow front projection
with a balcony above
so this part here on the proposed so all
of this existing
single-story front extension would be
gone
the pitcher front porch to the western
elevation here
as you view the site from ferry road
would also be removed
to the rear this pyramidal roofed
extension would also be altered so you
can see existing here
and then on the corresponding proposed
you've that's um been removed
so the the top elevations on the left
hand side existing right hand side
proposed
show the site as viewed from ferry road
and the proposal would result in the
original form of the building
where my cursor is here appearing more
distinct without some of the
somewhat sprawling and incongruous
additions
the same is true when viewed from the
front or the north so this is the
the the second elevations down so this
where my cursor's pointing is
looking south viewed from the north
um the front elevation of the building
as existing and then this is the
corresponding proposed
with the removal of the flat roof front
extension it would rationalize the
original building form
the character and appearance of the
original building would appear distinct
with the proposed full ridged gable
ended extension to the east which is
shown here by my cursor
appearing as a discrete edition the
proposal would simplify the building
form removing some of the existing
extensions that give a somewhat
cluttered appearance
the height of the proposed extension to
the east so the highest point is where
my curse is pointing here
would be not materially greater than the
existing building
only one ridge which is where my curse
is pointing to
would extend up to the chimney height
the others being substantially lower
such as here the roof ridges would give
the extension a distinct character
but would not appear unduly bulky or
dominant in scale
given the dual pitch roofs where space
between the roofs so all these these
parts here
would allow for views through which
would break up the visual massing
extensive glazing will be proposed to
the northern elevation which will give
diners the ability to take advantage
of used northwards across the river
crouch
take you next to the proposed site plan
which is on screen now and i'll point
out the designated heritage assets
that border the site's western boundary
so that's where my cursor is here
consisting of several listed buildings
and in addition
the historic crossing of the river
crouch is also considered a
non-designated heritage asset
the anchor itself however is not a
listed building
and you'll note that the larger
extension proposed to the eastern is to
the eastern side
and when viewed from ferry road the
highest ridge would appear
beyond the existing building take you
back
to the elevation here so it's this
elevation here
so you can see in the background that's
the proposed extension to the east
appearing beyond the existing building
but we consider that the scale and
sighting of the extension would not
harm and give rise to any harm to the
heritage assets
or their settings surrounding the site
the proposal would enhance the
appearance of the original building by
removing some of the rather unattractive
editions and the design of the eastern
extension
would contrast with the form of the
original building to add visual interest
there is no requirements extensions must
mimic existing buildings
and in this case it is considered that
the varying height roofs
form and design would be appropriate to
the riverside setting
the applicant has provided um
on screen now an image sorry
hopefully you can see that an image to
illustrate how the extension
and alterations would appear and to show
the finish proposed
which would consist of glazing and then
a timber cladding which would
go from ground floor level but also
extend all over the roof
as well if you contrast this with the
next
image which is the existing building as
viewed from the north
um you will see that the removal of the
front extension makes the original
building
appear more apparent so that contrasted
with
the proposed image
take you back to the proposed site
layout plan
the proposal seeks to increase floor
space and appropriate parking must
therefore be provided
you'll note that 23 additional parking
spaces are proposed in this area here
which is
at the present time is soft landscaped
and also some of the existing spaces
would be reconfigured
here the access would remain off ferry
road in total 72 spaces will be provided
which it is considered would be
acceptable the proposal seeks to enhance
the existing business
and thus help to secure the viability of
the business and the employment it
provides
consideration has been given to the
economic benefit that would arise
members will note
recommended conditions including
relating to drainage ecology and
landscaping
and subject to these and the others the
recommendation chairman is one of
approval
thank you if you could just
uh that's that's good right um
sonja worthington has got a statement
to read out on this one please okay
um this is uh this is from um
mr michael hendry uh from navigate
planning
on behalf of the applicants i would like
to take this
opportunity to thank the officer for a
well-reasoned report
and welcome the recommendation of
approval
the current application builds on the
previously withdrawn application
and the useful dialogue with the case
officer
and conservation officer around car
parking and design
which has continued throughout the
proposal
now delivers 72 car parking spaces
an increase of 23 spaces including
four disabled spaces and two electric
car charging points
along with 14 secure covered bicycle
parking spaces
the provision of car parking has been a
carefully considered balance
between providing as many spaces as
possible
within the required dimensions on as
small an area as possible
so that no cars are visible from the
river crouch
all the car parking spaces are in excess
of the minimum dimensions
contained in the parking standards which
for the 49 original spaces
is a significant improvement the
proposal
better reveals the original 1930s
building
and provides a contemporary contrast
that is visually interesting
while respecting its riverside location
the pitched roof arrangement of the
extension proposed
is reminiscent of a series of timber
boat houses or warehouses
while allowing views through the
roofscape that break up the development
and ensure that it does not appear
visually intrusive
the design makes use of the views of the
river crouch
while providing a larger more ergonomic
and spacious dining area
able in what circumstances to
accommodate up to 156
covers an increase of 25 covers
and in the current times would provide
greater space for social distancing
the proposal therefore seeks to
reinvigorate
the public house and ensure its ongoing
viability
by securing its and hulbridge's position
as a visitor destination the economic
development
officer supports both the development
and its design
due to its job creation increasing from
30 to 50 predominantly local jobs on
site
and supporting up to 60 jobs in the
supply chain
and visitor attracting potential and
concludes that the proposal
is bold and eye-catching and
serve to further highlight hulkbridge as
an important visitor
destination on the coastal path the
planning and conservation officers have
considered the design at length
including at a meeting on site with the
design team
and conclude that it is a is of high
quality
whilst responding to the opportunities
and constraints offered by the site
and the wider area the parish council
while having objected to the current
application on building design
grounds were supportive of the exact
same building design
in june 2020 albeit with fewer car
parking spaces
as you have heard the officers have
considered the issues carefully and have
concluded
that the proposal represents a positive
contribution to the area
both visually and economically questions
regarding external materials
construction activity and landscape
planting
can't be can be sensibly addressed by
suitably worded conditions
if members are minded to support the
application it is requested that the
wording of the following draft can
conditions be reconsidered condition
seven
brim very good to be restricted to the
new build
element only given the 1930s building is
unlikely to comply
and to allow provision for or as near as
practicably
viable as agreed with the local planning
authority
condition 13 landscape planting
to be required in the planting season
immediately preceding first use
to ensure that it is not damaged during
the construction phase
condition 19 existing drainage cleaning
and repair
to be required prior to above-ground
level works to enable this to be
undertaken
as part of the development phase i
reiterate
my support for the officer's
recommendation and trust that the
information provided will assist members
in the debate
okay thank you
um council ahoy as a visiting member and
ward member would you uh care to
lead off please uh thank you chairman
first of all just forgive me because i
might be
slow at times because i'm darting
between different um pdf files
and the um internet um
first of all i would just say that i
don't
object to an extension being built on
the anchor i think it would be good for
whole region
and be good for the anchor and obviously
it does it wouldn't
increase the employment in the area and
they do employ locally so that isn't the
reason i've called this in
um there are two reasons or two things i
have problems with one
more than the other the first one is
about parking um
the parking sizes are below standard i'd
much rather
actually put in parking spaces that are
within standard
um because obviously the for for
commercial premises the the parking
stand is a maximum not a minimum
and there is a public car park nearby
and this is
probably one of the occasions where i
would
would agree to having fewer parking
places to make them
very usable but i wouldn't object on
those grounds however
i think it's wise to draw councillors
attention to the fact that they are
undersized
all of them um the
main reason for getting in is the actual
design i do
disagree with the officers if you look
our term page 12 paragraph 3.20
you will see that the cladding being
used is siberian larch
um siberian larch is not native to essex
i think we'd all realize that from the
name of it um
i think the design itself is quite is
very distinctive and i'm not saying it's
a poor quality it's a high quality
design
but i think it's highly inappropriate
for the area it
is not it doesn't lend itself to the
character at the moment
within holbridge um if you look at
pictures from across the river it would
stand out
as being very different to the to the
holbridge side of the river it will be
highly distinctive
um i'll draw your attention to
paragraph this is where i'm losing it
130 of the mppf
it states that
permission should be refused for
development of poor design it isn't poor
design that fails to take
the opportunities available for
improving the character and quality of
the area
and the way it functions taking into
account any local design standards or
style guide
guiding plans or supplementary planning
documents obviously with regard to
rocha district council that would be the
essex design guide
if you look at the essex design guide
the appropriate use of materials
would be facing and roof material should
be selected from the range of regional
materials characteristic of essex or of
that part of essex where the project is
located
this means using those materials present
on pre-20th century buildings in
locality
the traditional range includes red
yellow stock and white gold bricks
smooth rendering black or white painted
horizontal weather balding
and then it goes on to say some others
obviously weatherboarding is very essex
and this is probably what i would expect
on something
in this area and in fact it's in pre
previous applications
this has been insisted on that the essex
weatherboarding is what should be used
not to my mind siberian
larch in addition the
the actual shape of the barns on
aren't particularly reminiscent of an
essex style
and i think the the actual style
together with the color of the siberian
mark
larch will make these stand out
a lot from the south wooden side of the
river i'd also add that
the land directly in front of the anchor
on the holby side
is green belt land and
although the building itself isn't in
greenbelt it is adjacent to greenbelt
land on the riverbank
and obviously there's green belt land to
the on the opposite bank to the
west as well so and this is also
adjacent to the um uh
the the coastal community um
coastal community area i think i've got
the name right there after i've lost the
page for that one
and the whole design just seems
inappropriate
on those bases and i think the
application should either be
refused on the basis that the design is
is out of character with the area and
not using local materials and not
inherent
in agreement with the essex design guide
or perhaps deferred if that's possible
for them to have a further
look at the style of the building thank
you chairman
okay thank you all right uh
move on to the members debates now
um i'd like to call councillor mrs shaw
first
please thank you chair um
when we went for the site visit which
was very good i was very i'm very
concerned
um with the parking as councillor hoyas
already
said um on the spaces but also the
the trees the mature trees that are
actually being cut down
or removed and we um what
are they going to actually put some
substantial trees back in
around um the green area to
because we're trying to be a green
council um
and i can't see why we're getting
removing
established trees that is one of my
concerns what i've got on this
application thank you
thank you um councillor wilson you put a
hand up
did that did you indicate you wanted to
speak yes please check yeah okay
go ahead um yeah it's an interesting one
because
um i certainly agree with uh council
high's point about using the essex
weatherboarding which i think is
much more in keeping with the area
originally and it probably comes down to
taste but um
originally when i saw the plans for this
i wasn't convinced that this would work
but having seen how it it will work
i'm actually in favor of it but i do
agree that whether we can defer
this and to see whether it's possible to
have
the the weatherboarding which is
definitely more in keeping rather than
using
materials from outside the area thank
you
councillor steptoe please
thank you chairman um could i ask the
officer to just put up the site plan
again please
it'll be there in a second do you want
to start making your point please
uh yes i wanted to in the first instance
to identify
um i'm unclear as to what is uh on part
of the uh
drawing there in terms yeah that's
lovely thank you
um the to the um you've got the overall
red line going around the
uh development site to the
left top corner of that there is an area
there it's got
sort of a circle in the middle of that
with the square in the middle
um can you identify what that site
is uh in relation is are they buildings
i'm not clear what that particular
area is not adjacent to that
do you want to just answer that one kha
please
so essentially as i recall it was it was
open space and
recreational space that's that's what i
wanted to
to to identify as to what that is
are they is that buildings there or are
they it looks as if there may be some
buildings of some description
bear with me a second and i'll come back
to that is that okay hold on
okay thank you for that um the other
concern i do have
uh i share council hoy's concerns uh
i don't have a problem with the the the
overall
um fact that it's extending the existing
business and i think
uh it's good for the the for the area i
do have a problem with the
the overall design um
of the uh the building um
i don't mean this in a nasty way but
it's very tantamount to uh
what i've seen of cattle sheds um
in the the general design of of the
building so
i i think it's well out of character
within that particular
area just interrupting you there
counselor
the the view being shared now uh has got
the aerial view of the
the question that you asked thank you so
much
so yeah that's open there what is there
is a building just
just at the bottom of that building
there what is that building there
is that another house
i think that's a house but i can just
confirm that
i just wanted to know if that had any
relevance and
to the recycle
okay okay thank you i'll carry on if i
make sure
yes regards to the parking spaces um
yes the overall size of cars these days
is a lot bigger and a lot wider
um particularly when you look at some of
the um
larger vehicles that their public now
now buy
so i would agree with council ahoy that
the parking standards should be observed
there is a
very large car park right adjacent to
the site
it's uh right next door so it's not a
big issue
in terms of the parking and i would have
said we didn't need to
be over worried about the number of
parking spaces
provided they met the criteria
so chairman i i personally like to
propose
um two things that uh the planning
should be rejected on the basis
of the uh overall
appearance and design of the building uh
it's going to be
um seen from for quite some distance
right across the river it's going to be
quite a
substantial uh site across the river and
across there
and that the parking spaces should
meet the criteria so i'd like to post
that chairman
okay thank you um
i'll just carry on through the members
making their points
before we go any further on that one uh
canceler
mrs mason um you'd indicated
you mr chairman um again
i i share counselor hoy's and stephtow's
concerns
the parking standards the officer and as
i misheard henry paul
said that the parking spaces were
compliant
the report would indicate that some are
and some aren't could we have some
clarity on the car parking spaces and if
they
are all up to standard place
okay i'll come to that in a in a moment
a councillor stanley
okay mr chairman that was just a
question that i
wanted to ask unless council stanley can
supply the answer
was there anything else that you wanted
to add yes i i
think i would look to second council
sector
um move for refusal
i'd like to speak to it now if i may
i i share the concerns and i also
share the fact that this
in principle i've seen nothing wrong
with the extension that's proposed
as far as the footprint and the
principle of extending
the property goes the car parking
gives me a concern i haven't been able
to locate the cycle
storage on the site but i think it's
near
the property that council septo was
questioning i think it's those little
squiggles on the map but i can't be
sure um so that is
just a question perhaps again for
officers to clarify and
i can see no provision for bin
or refuse storage or for access
to bin and refuse storage so again
that needs to be clarified um
my main concerns echo those that have
already been expressed
the ridge heights on 3
19 i think it is there with me except
they would create a
vibrant facade facing the river
and a range of interesting spaces within
that's very subjective the tallest
volume containing the main space would
align with the ridge of the existing
hub again that is rather is ingenuous
because it
aligns with the chimney not with the
building
the ridge heights the highest ridge
lines would be 8.6 meters
6.4 and seven
pairing in the report itself it says it
compares with
6.4 7.1 5.7 so
the ridge also the picture of the route
ridges the fact that they're
the design of the bridge i think is
inappropriate so the whole
design of that roof space
or i feel is out of uh
keeping with the area they say there's
no
consideration of no harm well that game
is subjective
it is so out of keeping and i believe it
is visually intrusive
on the air area but again that is
i will accept a subjective point of view
but if you look at the design
guide the cp1 and dn1 i don't believe
that it that this application
equates with the policy cp1 i don't
think it says it requires development to
obtain a high quality
design that reflects local
character and distinctiveness
i could agree with the distinctiveness i
can't agree with the local character
i have similar concerns about the
materialistic
of the material being used and i think
most members would have concerns with
that
and bear with me i'm having to flick
through
various screens as we all do these days
um
the applicants say that they've got the
support of the economic development
officer and yes
the mppf says that we have to take
business liability into account the
approach taken should allow each area to
build on its strengths
again i don't think this is building on
its strengths but when it comes down to
it the
fundamental thing is a planning
application
and the planning application to my mind
does not have a good design that's and
the material is inappropriate with the
area
and there are too many questions at the
moment i would certainly second refuse
them
thank you mr chairman um perhaps
when the officers managed to get the
answers to those questions regarding
the car parking the cycle storage and
the bin storage
they could elucidate thank you we'll
come back to answers in a bit
cancer stanley then
yes thank you chairman um i concur with
uh the remarks made already
um and um having visited the site
um the uh um well
i'm going to say the subtitle
used in that country uh because of the
atmospheres that uh that he's going to
get the
the uh weather and what have you but i
don't believe it's
it would be it
it's going to be very much like um
oak when it when it um
gets older it will it will go really
dark
um really sort of sil what would say
dark silvery grey
but i don't believe it's the right it's
the right material to use
um in essex in any case it it doesn't
contrast very well with uh
with original buildings so yes i do
concur with
with what's been said already especially
with car parking
we're told that um it is of the minimum
standard
but um it doesn't seem like it is of the
minimum standard every car parking space
so obviously some carpet car parking
spaces will be
for minis uh or uh that size of vehicle
and some car parking spaces will just
about do for other large cars
which has already been noted so that's
another thing
that perhaps the officers can elaborate
on thank you
thank you councillor
thank you chairman um i think
i'll be only repeating a number of
points that have already been raised but
just to to go over
um my view on on this particular
application
um i don't object with the uh
the overall um basic design
uh and and uh and the yet the structure
but i
there has been a number of points raised
and i do um
concur with them about the material
used which doesn't seem to be in keeping
and is
going to be locally sourced um and also
with the overall height of the uh the
tallest uh part of the extension which
um
is um um although um
is uh doesn't uh have a height
above the existing building it may be a
little bit
more domineering so i think that um that
the height
of the uh the tallest parts um should be
looked at
so that he doesn't become uh a dominant
part
of the overall um uh structure
um and uh the other the other matter
which has been raised number of times in
relation to car parking we should
in in this instance insist that the uh
car parking sizes meet the standard
especially bearing in mind
if there is any overflow there is a um
an adjacent car park that
councillor steptoe has already pointed
out
and so that's that's my particular
views on this thank you jim okay thank
you for
for my part um i
i don't mind the design i think it's
quite a character form design
and representative of many a sailing
bard uh
sailing um sailing barn that i've seen
in in numerous locations
um i don't even have a an issue with the
the scandinavian larch that's described
as the the material
and i think it's very representative of
the the trading that's happened on the
crouch for
for many years and and still happens now
up at
bontic wharf parking standards is a
question but i suspect that could be
quite
easily dealt with by by terms of
variation if it was felt uh that that
necessary
and i'm not inclined to um
support the hindrance to development of
uh
and growth of of economic development in
that that part of holbridge
and i certainly think the design tidies
up
the the the the bits and pieces that
have been added to the existing building
over
time but um before we we we move on
i'll ask the officers if they could come
back
and answer some questions with regard to
landscaping parking spaces
cycle spaces bins and just generally
round up
the the package of questions that have
been put by members
thank you thank you
i'll try and take them in turn okay i'm
just going to share my screen again
so first of all counselor steptoe in
answer to your question about
the building that's adjacent to um
kind of north um part of the site
it's a house it's that that's the view
on ferry road
um so it's this property here
pardon is that listed um i
don't think that one is there is um it's
set out in the report
there are a number of buildings to the
western side opposite on the other side
of ferry road that are listed
um and we've taken into account the sort
of impact on those
designated heritage assets as well as
the river crossing which is a
non-designated heritage asset
um i think our view is that the
extension
um to the eastern side is far enough
away that it wouldn't harm the setting
of this
this area of ferry road um because as
you go
up the road um i guess you would view it
um to the to the rear um
of the existing building
if i then take um
we had a comment about trees um so if i
just take you to the
proposed site plan um there are going to
be a number of trees
there aren't any that are um like
really good high quality sort of a grade
trees that are kind of really old and
have
really good um visual amenity value but
there are some trees
in this location um our view is that
they could be adequately compensated for
so what we could do
is just reinforce the landscaping
condition
um just to specify that we're expecting
some kind of mature tree planting to
happen
in and around this area here it is
indicated but we could just substantiate
that
um in the landscaping condition that's
proposed just to reassure you that you
will get some um compensatory tree
planting
um we then went on to
parking spaces so
if i take you back to
bear with me
so this is the existing and
proposed site layout plan so hopefully
you can see that on the screen
so there is an existing um car park at
the site
and those spaces do not meet the
preferred base size
um or the minimum base size as it stands
now
and what the proposal seeks to do is
reconfigure those existing spaces so
although they wouldn't meet the
preferred
base size now of 2.9 by 5.5
they would be made bigger and that is
set out in the report
at in and around paragraph 3.74
a little bit before that as well so
you're getting some betterment in terms
of
the existing parking arrangement and
then these new spaces
would all meet the minimum base size
i'd be cautious about a reason for
refusal around parking base size
if you're if you would accept um
a lower number of bays but
that those new bays would all meet the
standard
because what you could achieve here is a
parking solution where all the new bays
meet the preferred base size but you
just wouldn't get as many parking spaces
because there's a balance to be struck i
guess between you know the loss of
too much of the soft landscaping and the
impact on
on that versus the
car parking spaces and those standards
for this
type of use being a maximum and also we
give some consideration to the fact that
there's an existing public car park
close by and that it's in a sort of
an area where some people would walk to
this site anyway
so there is going to be some betterment
to this parking solution and i think
there is
a way in which we could achieve a
parking solution for the new bays
that would all meet the preferred base
size but you'd have to accept that i
think you'd have a few less spaces
in number um
in terms of bin storage
um
sorry
i'll just take you to the proposed
ground floor plan so hopefully that's
what
you can see on screen now and there is a
key it doesn't specify exactly where
the bins are stored at the site but i
think they would be in this area to the
rear of the site here
there is sufficient space to accommodate
refuse
bins at the site um and the cycle
bays are where my cursor is just here
and
so that's where the cycle bays will be
provided and there's a condition around
the provision of those
i think that was all the specific
questions um that were answered
sort of asked um apologies if i've
missed anything and please speak up
i'll go back to that i would just say in
terms of the design that
um yes the if i take you back to
the image that's been provided so to
give you
sort of um an impression of what it
would look like
so i think in terms of the essex design
guide actually
the building form does quite closely
follow um some of the
um requirements of traditional buildings
in essex so in terms of the quite
steeply pitched roof
and the kind of low eaves height um the
dual pitched roof it's quite a simple
form
so in those respects actually um these
structures do kind of follow some of
those
some of that guidance that we have
referred to in our policy
um i take your point about the the
proposed material not being locally
sourced
but i think what the applicant is
seeking to do is providing something
that would contrast with
the existing building and provide visual
interest
it's not a conservation area so perhaps
there is
an opportunity here to do something a
little bit different
that would stand out um potentially be
of an asset to the locality um
i'll leave it at that i think if there's
any questions i haven't answered please
get please let me know
um just before we move on a councillor
williams i think you did
you'd indicate and you haven't spoken
yet
yeah thank you chairman um i i liked
many other as we went to the um site
visit um
so the particularly pretty building as
it is at the moment and i think this
would only enhance it
and i think the true benefit of this
will come from the other side of the
river
or for people using using the river
perhaps but
personally i would support this
application thank you
thank you um cancer steptoe
um you moved for refusal
and you had a seconder so for the sake
of clarity now you've heard from
officers uh and for members could you
restate please your reason for ref your
reasons for refusal please take the
debate on
thank you thank you first because
i asked questions of the officers and
i've only had a partial response
people weren't answered at the time i've
not had the opportunity to speak to them
you'll be a you'll be able to speak
after councillor scepto
when we've got clarity about what we're
talking to thank you
thank you thank you thank you chairman
um
i believe there was a photograph or a
picture mock-up picture of the
view that would be of the building go
looking from the road across the
building
am i correcting that or did i imagine
that it's possible to have that out
of the proposed building
yep bear with me i'll just put that on
the screen
is that the view you were after so these
are the enemies
that's correct yes thank you um
my concerns are with regards to the car
parking spaces
i think we need to make sure that they
are compliant with our
policy and standards um there is a a
large car park right next door
uh to the property um so i don't think
you know for the sake of uh
losing a few parking spaces i think it
would be much
much better for the patrons coming along
so i i would still move that particular
point
i'm very concerned um i have don't have
a problem with the fact that they're
extending it
uh and the uh the design the overall
design of the building
i do feel that the impact that it will
have certainly looking from the view
looking at the side on view there the
roof of the extension building is going
to be dominant particularly of the
materials that it
is using so i concerned it is that it's
out of keeping
in terms of the materials used not
necessarily the design
okay thank you um so so
just for clarity members the reasons for
refusal
are based on the the the dominance
of the design the the material has being
used
and the non-compliance with parking
standards
that's that that's fair cancer step toe
yes thank you thank you chairman
i'd accept that thank you um
so so members we're now going to focus
our debate
on the reasons for refusal which is
those and i'll come to you now
again councillor mason
thank you
about the uh car parking spaces when we
have a minimum
size i don't think we should accept
anything less and i certainly concur
with the
proposal that if we have to lose one or
two spaces
bearing in mind the locality and there
is a
public car park then our minimum should
not be compromised
and minimum isn't our preferred size
it's even less
so we have a preferred size of let me
just check
here um of 5.5 by 2.9
the minimum is 5 by 2.5 and we're not
even achieving that
so certainly that is a matter of concern
i noticed the officer mentioned the
essex design guide well
this council hasn't adopted the essex
design
guide and probably for very good reason
in the essex has such a variation
of buildings that the designs
in north essex are very different from
the designs
in this area so i do think it's the over
dominance
and that aligns with the ridge heights
um is a problem um especially the
highest one
the design is out of keeping over
dominance
and the concern over the material
i think has been expressed by a few
members so
thank you mr chair thank you councillor
hookway just on the points for
refusal that we're discussing please
thank you chairman um yes uh cancer
stepso
summit our eyes the uh the concerns that
i have
um uh quite well um and so
um i do support uh
uh the arguments and um on the basis of
that
um i would say um that um in relation to
uh uh if if the proposal is
is um doesn't uh get refused that
uh we could look at a deferment because
this is a matter of design
and it could be something that the uh um
the applicant should be able to sort out
with our officers to get uh
something uh back to us which is much
more in fitting with
what the arguments of so far come up
with during the course of this meeting
thank you cancer fd
thank you chairman um i i disagree with
the other speakers on this side but more
agree with you what you said earlier
this is i don't particularly like the
design but it's subjective
and i can't tell people what to build it
shouldn't be refused just because we
don't like the look of something
and also the minimum sizes we've got
minimums we've got the new minimum sizes
and new spaces where the old spaces are
what we've had there for years it'd be
nice to maybe reduce the size a couple
of spaces to get a little bit better
size but
it's going to be better than what it was
so i'll just put that in there
thank you uh members i think uh
we're in a position now oh just finally
from council stanley then
quickly please
thank you chairman um yes uh i have to
say that um
just because we're lose it's not that
we're
asking them to change the car parking
spaces that are already there
it's the new car parking spaces that
we're concerned with
and not the old ones so yes we should be
able to have a minimum
we've got a policy to to do that and to
have minimum size
also i'd like to point out that it is
essex
and not siberia or anywhere else in the
world
this is essex and if we cannot i do
agree
yes there are certain occasions where we
can
sort of say well that would that looks
really nice or whatever the case may be
but we're looking at we're looking at a
different project altogether
we criticize
house building in the way we want
certain bricks certain
uh faces of of of places
rendering and such like and yet here we
are
saying exactly the wrong thing with
criticized builders for doing
the wrong design of houses and yet we're
saying at the moment
this we're not going to criticize this
well we should be there to criticize
that's all i've got to say okay thank
you so members we
we've had a good debate the points uh
the key points have been
uh thoroughly explored
back on one point councillor smith yes
go on then
so apologies i'd like to be just really
clear
about the parking and i'd like i know um
councillor mason maybe wanted me to come
back so
can i just share my screen with you
so in the report hopefully you can see
an extract of the report on the screen
so um sort of page 18 we're looking at
end of page 18 beginning of page 19.
um so the existing car part would be
remodel
remodeled we can't be expected to read
something of that size
no sorry i'm not i'm not expecting you
to read it um i'm just
just if you could just um listen to me i
don't you don't need to read it
um the parking bay dimensions would be
increased
for the existing bays so that they would
meet the minimum
okay and the additional 23 spaces
as currently proposed would exceed the
minimum
but they wouldn't quite meet the maximum
preferred base size
so i think what we could what i'd
a little bit concerned about a reason
for refusal around the parking base if
you are comfortable
that the existing bays would at least
meet the minimum
and the new base could meet the
preferred size
as long as you accept there would be a
reduction in the number
because we could achieve that through a
condition um
just wanted to make make that point i
think it's clear that all of these
spaces are going to meet the minimum
and that the new ones are going to be
slightly bigger than that and
could be bigger if you wanted to reduce
the number
overall
uh this is your reason for refusal can
you
uh can you you just uh
confirm what what your preference is
there
you're just on mute at the moment thank
you
if the committee is of a mind to um
approve the application uh yes i think
it
uh would be sufficient that is a
condition as described by the officer
um that the existing parking spaces
uh meet the minimum and so they're
upgrading slightly
and that the new parking spaces meet the
proper
preferred i'm not sure how many parking
spaces that we would lose
but i can't imagine it's going to be
more than about four three or four
overall in terms of your reason for
refusal that's been
seconded rather than an approval
do you still want to have non
compliance with parking standards as a
reason for refusal
on on the same basis as i've said of the
conditions
are you still content seconding that
just for clarity
i do need counsellor mrs mason before we
can go forward on that one
right um
don't we seem to have lost her there um
were there any other members
sorry mr were you able to hear my
question
yes i was i'm trying to read it on a
different screen which obviously makes
things
very difficult the minimum as i
understand it the minimum
car parking space which in my mind is
slightly inadequate anyway being in size
the size of cars is five by 2.5
again if the officer can confirm that
all the car parking spaces
will meet or exceed that that would be
helpful
do you want to go on katy please oh yes
sorry um yes so i know
it was on the screen um but it does say
a freeze of reference
at um 3.70
paragraph 3.70 um
the existing car part would be remodeled
to provide larger bays for the existing
49 car parking spaces
and that those bays would be to a
standardized
five meters long by 2.6 wide
to ensure that all 72 spaces are usable
so
yes the existing spaces would be able to
meet the minimum
okay thank you thank you that clarifies
that point
so in terms of the the question
were you still content to say second in
council steptoes
reason for refusal on the design
and appearance materials aspect and the
parking standards
well the design materials and the ridge
height yes certainly
on the pakistan design set that
convenient for perhaps if i suspect
so i come back i come back to you again
councillor steptoe
um are you still content to to move
forward with your reason for refusal
sort of omitting the parking standards
no i'm i'm happy to accept the
office of officers advice on that point
okay
okay right we we we need to move on with
this
uh met members um
councillor getting it you're not going
to introduce a new point are you
you just
sorry um i was concerned about the
uh the materials and um
as part of what was already been raised
so
i was talking on that point uh if
if i could get advice from the officer
would it be able to be a condition that
we could
um enforce a condition for locally
sourced materials
um i think the issue is that
the design is quite unique it's trying
to do something that's a little bit
different in terms of the finish so
although the the actual
form is quite traditional it's got gable
ends and a dual pitch roof
um actually the fact that this material
is going to be
vertical and it's going to go up the
sides and over the roof
um potentially makes it more challenging
for us to just condition
that different materials are used okay
um potentially we could differ
you know i'm thinking that um and also i
think what's been
said so far is not just about the
materials in terms of the reason for
refusal that's been
put forward um and that we're talking to
at the moment
um it's not just the materials but i've
also written down points about the roof
being over dominant and it just being of
a design that's out of keeping
with the locality so if it were sort of
a proposal where an applicant is
specified
a brick and we didn't think that brick
was the right color
um then yes i would say to you we could
easily condition that
but actually the whole design sort of
the materials are intertwined
with the design in this in this case um
and actually if we start to just put
conditions on
the actual design might not work i think
i'm content that we need to vote on this
because uh
it's it's substantial um
in its description the reason for
refusal um
so some members cancer steptoe seconded
back out to mrs mason has indicated
a reason for refusal around the
the bonk the material and so on there is
the acceptance
that parking standards need to be uh
also looked at as an aside but i think
we've had
enough discussion now so we need to go
to a vote
for refusal so if you're saying yes
you are supporting the refusal if you're
saying no you're against the refusal
so i'm going to go go through now um
counselor fd um and can we have the
usual thing about the
the recorded vote so it's you would like
a recorded vote
and then the the the uh your actual vote
councillor fd no recorded votes and
against
refusal thank you
councillor gooding no recorded
go uh vote and for the refusal
councillor hawkway
thank you chairman uh no recorded votes
and
for refusal counselor yano
no recall would have vote uh against
against the refusal for that against the
refusal
thank you cancer mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no need for a
recorded vote
and for the refusal
counsel mr shaw no recorded vote and
against refusal
counselor mr shaw no recorded vote
for the refusal myself no recorded vote
and against the refusal councillor
stanley
for the re uh for the refusal no
recorded vote
councillor steptoe no recorded vote
and for the refusal councillor williams
uh no recorded vote done against the
refusal
councillor wilson
no recorded vote in the game's refusal
six six sonia
right i will use my chairman's casting
vote um against the motion that's been
put forward
um so that motion for refusal is
lost we now move on
to the recommendation
that is printed uh over over
five separate pages
before we go to a vote on that there are
a
a number of things clearly that are
going to
come into this first of all um
parking um there's been a clear
indication
that uh from a good number of members
that parking uh needs to be conditioned
in a different way to achieve um
better compliance with standards um
katie could you on that single item
please
just describe what you feel is
appropriate in terms of condition
what's achievable
yep so i think what we need to do
is either add a new condition
or we could amend the existing condition
i'm just looking for the number but what
i propose to do is either by mending an
existing condition or proposing a new
one
is to ensure that the existing
bay spaces meet at least the minimum
and that the new spaces um
meet the preferred bay size
with the understanding that that would
reduce the number
because what we wouldn't have is any
greater
area set aside for parking
on that single item can any member
just indicate if they've got an issue
with that councilor wilson could you
just
just stick to that one issue please
i'm sorry chairman i was going to move
for deferment
um on that um issue
and the other two issues as well i i'm
i'm going to move to a vote on
on on this one at the moment
um so so that so members there's a
solution to the parking
discussion
members please thank you let's point out
with with regard to
which has been a significant part of
order mr chairman please
yes counselor mason on a point of order
on the point of order unlimited you had
a motion on a table earlier and a second
day and you didn't allow debate
for a while on the motion for refusal
now you've got an um of a member putting
a motion and you're not asking for a
second
i'm happy
thank you i'll second that motion please
um i did say i was moving
to the recommendation and that's what
i'll be doing at this moment in time
so um the next significant point
that was made was regarding the
materials
that were um suggested there was the
indication
from a number of members about sourcing
a more local material
katie if you'd like to pass a comment on
that particular issue please
we we could um put
a condition on that says that they
should you know we could look into it
in terms of materials um but
what i would say is generally conditions
are discharged
by officers rather than coming back to
members
so i think that they have been quite
clear in what they're proposing in terms
of the external finish
so whether they can source that
particular or something very similar
and so that the appearance would be
exactly the same as what's proposed but
it would be a more um
more local i don't know exactly how
local it would be to
to to essex um i think that's trickier
right okay members uh
in terms of uh having clarity on the
issue of um the materials
would any members like to speak
specifically
about the materials
uh cancer fd you indicated
thank you chairman um the materials i'm
i think you're making nice been
subjectively again
i i quite agree that you make a nice
look along the crouch
looking over at it there isn't really if
i remember correctly from the crouch
there's
a brandy whole yacht club a little bit
beside it but other than that it's
mainly caravan parks and it might quite
a nice focal point
with the materials that are asked to be
used and as katy says the way it's going
to be used i don't think
we could have an essex type of finish on
it
with the way it's designed thank you
chairman
thank you uh cancer williams
on materials please materials thank you
chairman
um i suspect that s6 boarding
type of a style of wood rather than a
type of wood
so this this may make um to me it looks
very much like
a thatched roof in the picture so
perhaps it would enhance here let's
let's try something a bit different
shall we just just for a change
cancer stanley thank you chairman
um under the essex guide
for localism on on buildings and what
have you
essex balding is not a particular way it
is put together
essex balding is using the local
materials and
we've got ash we've got oak we've got
all
all manners of wood if if you want to
put wood up that will actually
enhance the building especially oak and
i know it's very expensive
and i don't know how much siberian uh
wood is but it's probably some
you know a lot cheaper and a lot cheaper
to import as well
but i do think that we've got some
natural materials
in essex and it would it really would
enhance the place
using the essex building and material
not coming from a foreign country that
we don't particularly use any of their
stuff that's in
whole bridge in any case so that's my
point
thank you uh cancer hawkway
thank you chairman um i think um
from what the the office has stated in
relation to material
is um intertwined with the design on
this um i don't think it's going to be
possible as as she has stated to
condition um a material change which is
probably what the majority of the
committee is looking at
um so i think that
on that basis if um if members are not
happy with the material and or the um
the the design in whatever aspect then
um
then they're gonna have to use their
vote accordingly
and perhaps we might be able to get uh
an alternative vote on deferment
uh cancer mrs mason
i i i just want to um
say that i'm very concerned that the
debate on refusal was allowed to
wasn't put forward and now we're
debating
you're stopping debate and only allowing
fixed points um
there's nothing i can do you're chairing
it so that's fine but i would like to
register a complaint
right you do that in in due course the
former white
councillor gooding yes thank you chair
um my concern for the materials
um being sourced locally is is the main
issue
and if there was a deferment
to ensure that we as a rochefort
district council
trying to be greener in the future
that would certainly appeal to me as
part of
this application
thank you um the
other the the other main point that came
from the previous debate um
and reason for refusal was about the
the scale and mass of
of that so on that particular point did
anyone
want to say anything further
okay uh cancer stepped out
yes thank you chairman uh i do feel that
it's going to be quite overbearing
um particularly as the roof and the
walls are all going to be the same
material
there's going to be any sort of break up
on that so i still have that as a
concern
i also pick up on council gooding's
point that
we do need to be greener and of course
siberian
timber obviously has got to travel a
fair distance to get to us
so i do have a concern about that okay
thank you
i think we've covered the the main items
that were around
the reason for refusal are there any
other items
um where that members would like to
raise
with regard to this before we go to a
vote
on the on the recommendation for
approval
okay thank you all right members
we have a recommendation for refusal
printed over far sorry a recommendation
for
approval printed over five five pages
we have got um a
small amendment which has uh members
have accepted with regard
to um the car parking and further
discussion via condition
with the applicant regarding that so
if we now go to the
uh to the vote please for approval
counselor sorry just let me uh make sure
i've got my
table right cancer fd
nobody called he votes and for approval
chairman
councillor gooding
no recorded vote and against approval
okay councillor hawkway
chairman uh no recorded vote and against
approval
thank you councilliano
no recorded vote and for the approval
thank you
councillor mrs mason now recorded vote
and against refusal against the
principle
yeah yeah counsellor mr shaw
recorded vote and for approval
cancer mr shaw no recorded vote against
approval
uh councillor smith i am now recorded
vote for
approval counselor stanley
no recorded vote and against the
approval
council steptoe no recorded vote
and against review approval thank you
councillor williams and they're recorded
vote
and full approval thank you councillor
wilson
no recorded vote and against approval
75 yeah
so that that item is not approved
so all that is left for us really
members
is a motion to defer this item
further councillor hookway
thank you chairman yes i move for a
motion of deferment
um cancer steptoe happy to second that
chair
okay sonia do we need to take a formal
vote on that one
yes please chairman okay just for
um members it's quite clear do we defer
or
or not um councillor fd
for deferment chairman councillor
gooding
ford deferment thank you chairman
councillor hawkway
poor deferment chairman brianno
paul deferment councillor mrs mason
no recorded vote and ward of berman
thank you
mr shaw board deferment thank you
cancer mr shaw poor deferment
i agree it's deferred uh cancer stanley
ford department council
for determine council williams
sorry against you furman
or deferral please thank you the members
clearly that
item is going to be deferred the
officers have heard
quite clearly um the the nature of the
discussion
don't know whether the applicant has
been listening in but clearly
um the the items that are of concern to
members
uh and have led to their views have been
fairly well
expanded on and hopefully uh that will
be back with us before too long
thank you very much that item is
deferred
on to item seven this is
ashington pavilion ashington road
rochford
a proposed change of use of pavilion
um is kt going to present
this one again please thank you i'll
just share my screen with you
members this application seeks to change
the use of path to the ashendum pavilion
edged red
on the plan on the screen this building
is located adjacent to king george's
playing fields and served by a car park
or fashiondam road
opposite the junction with york road
just take you to the next plan
so on screen now is the proposed floor
plan so the proposal is modest and seeks
to change the use of
only some 22 square meters of floor
space to provide an
office and meeting room space which it
is intended would be used by ashendon
parish council
the remaining floor space will be
retained for use as changing facilities
and as a play group
take you to the
so this just shows an aerial image of
the site
so this is the building here that my
curse is pointing to and you'll see just
to the north there are residential
properties
um bordering the wider site and to the
south
but the proposed office would not give
rise to any harm to residential amenity
by way of noise and disturbance
the playing field fields and buildings
on the wider site are all within the
green belt
however no increase in footprint of the
building is proposed
and the change of use would be an
appropriate form of development in the
green belt
which would have no adverse impact on
openness or on the character and
appearance of the area
the site is served by adequate car
parking and the recommendation
is therefore one of approval thank you
this is a fairly uh fairly small
application
but come to us as it's uh as it's the
richard district council one
um councillor steptoe i'll let you lead
off on this one please
thank you chairman very simply i don't
think this is detrimental to the area
it brings a building into more far
better use
uh it's a benefit to the community and i
would like to move
approval thank you very much
councillor williams
thank you chairman um i totally agree
with the council to step down i will
second that
thank you
i think one of the less controversial uh
applicant
applications we've had before us uh
no one else has indicated we'll go
straight to
a vote on this recommendation for
approval that's been
uh moved by council steptoe and seconded
by councillor williams
i think everyone's uh quite confident
that they've seen all the evidence and
properly informed enough to come to a
decision
so um in terms of whether you're for or
against the recommendation for approval
counselor fd or recommendation for
approval no we called you vote thank you
chairman q
councillor gooding for approval
no recorded vote thank you chairman
councillor hawkway
thank you chairman uh no recorded vote
and for
the uh um for the application
thank you canceliano no recorded
vote in full approval okay that's the
mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and
for approval okay council mr shaw
no recording vote and for approval thank
you chairman
mr shaw no recording vote for approval
uh myself no recorded vote for approval
councillor stanley no
m4 thank you chairman thank you council
steptoe
no recorded vote and for the uh approval
thank you
councillor williams no recorded vote and
for the approval thank you
wilson and no recorded vote and for the
approval
okay thank you very much members that
item was unanimously
approved
next we move on to item
eight which is a referred item
um little standbridge hall farm little
standby horn lane standbridge
demolition of existing commercial units
an erection of three purpose-built
commercial units
and others changes so
again uh katy is going to present to us
on this one please
thank you
this application sees to demolish
existing commercial units and construct
three purpose-built commercial units
for b8 storage and distribution and b1c
light industrial use the plan on screen
shows the site edge red is part of a
wider site which is edge blue
of little stanbridge hall farm located
at the end of little stanbridge hall
lane
i'll just take you to the next planned
parenthood
sorry apologies
the site is in the green belt where
national and
rochford's own council policy is clear
that inappropriate development that is
harmful to greenbelt openness should be
refused
unless very special circumstances exist
that clearly outweigh the harm
the plan on screen shows the layout of
the four existing buildings which would
be to
to be demolished so these are where my
cursor is here so you've got one ridge
line here
second one third one and fourth
change of use of existing redundant
agricultural buildings can be
appropriate development in the greenbelt
having no impact on openness as a result
of reusing
existing buildings and indeed planning
permission was granted for the reuse of
these existing buildings
on this site here in 2018 for business
use
this application however proposes new
buildings in place of these
where new buildings are proposed in the
greenbelt as on previously developed
land
rochford's own planning policy and
national policy requires that new
buildings must not have
an adverse greater impact on openness in
the green belt
take you to another plan
so on screen now you can see
extracts of the existing um
site layout plan to the left hand side
so the the four buildings that are
better to be demolished here where my
cursor is
and then this is the same site layout
but this is the proposed
and so you have one building here
proposed one centrally
and then one to the north so these are
the three proposed buildings
in this case however not all of the
application site is previously developed
land
the northernmost building where my
cursor is here
would not be cited on that part of the
site on which existing buildings are
sited
but would rather encroach onto the open
field to the north
so by reference point this corner here
um if you go along
the existing building does not extend
north
um from this line here whereas on the
proposal
that point there is here and
approximately half of the footprint of
this northern building
would be outside of the previously
developed site
approximately half of the footprint of
the northernmost building would encroach
onto the undeveloped greenbelt
this would not be insubstantial given
the scale of this building
at some 46 metres in width given this
encroachment into undeveloped greenbelt
the proposal would amount to
inappropriate development according to
national greenbelt policy
although the total floor space proposed
will be reduced slightly
the proposed buildings will be
substantially greater in height and bulk
if i take you to the existing
elevations
so these are the elevations of the
existing building
the existing buildings are very low
level with shallow pitched roofs
and they blend into the royal in rural
landscape and are rather inconspicuous
i have some photos as well to show you
so that's one of the photos of the
existing buildings
this is the central space in between um
so that
they're quite um compact and sort of
positioned close together
um the eve's height is low as is the
ridge height so the
ground level to ridge on all four
buildings is 3.8 meters
and then this is a view taken from a
wider perspective
um and then if i take you to
the proposed so these are the proposed
elevations
in contrast the proposed buildings will
be substantially greater in scale and
far more visually dominant
the proposed buildings with very
significantly greater height
would have a much greater adverse impact
on greenbot openness
the difference in height between
existing and the highest proposed
building would be over double
from 3.8 meters to ridge to 8.8 meters
to ridge
so that 8.8 is from from this point here
my cursor is
down to the ground level
i'll take you to the plan three
so again this space between buildings
would be
extended and but it wouldn't be open and
landscaped but this space in between
would be hard surface and it would be
space for vehicles to turn and for large
vehicles to access
into these units additional parking is
also proposed so where my cursor is here
on the existing plan you can see this
soft landscaped area to the um and what
that would be replaced with is this
quite extensive area of parking
this would be substantial and also have
an adverse impact on green but openness
taken as a whole the proposal would
appear substantially more developed
than the low-lying existing buildings
which are closely positioned
i also take you to
an image that has been provided by the
applicant
so this shows an image so 3d image to
give you an idea of what the proposed
oops apologies buildings would look like
so the volume of the buildings proposed
would also increase very substantially
from existing a total of about seven
thousand six hundred cubic meters
to some twelve thousand seven hundred
cubic meters
an increase of some five thousand cubic
meters in visual and openness terms this
would equate to approximately the volume
of the centrally positioned building
so that volume there is additional
compared to what is existing volume on
site at present
essentially if the central building were
not part of the proposal and the other
buildings cited closer together
such that the whole proposal were
contained within the previously
developed part of the site
then the redevelopment proposal here
would be more aligned to the council's
adopted greenbelt policy
and national policy which seeks to
protect the openness of the green belt
it falls then to consider because
obviously all three buildings are
proposed here with the consequent
um significant increase in volume
whether there are any very special
circumstances which exist which would
clearly outweigh the harm to the green
belt and members will note the
consideration given
to very special circumstances in the
report the site already however benefits
from planning permission to reuse the
redundant agricultural buildings for
commercial use
the proposal is therefore not required
to facilitate economic benefit via
diversification at the site
the existing buildings can and already
do or
in commercial use
whilst redevelopment of the previously
developed land at this site could accord
with greenbelt policy in principle
this proposal pushes the development
onto undeveloped greenbelt and is too
great in scale to be acceptable with
regard to greenbelt policy
the buildings would be much higher and
much greater in volume
significant weight to which must be
attached in decision making
the proposal is therefore one of refusal
for the reason as stated in the report
thank you we have a statement that's
going to be read out on this one
sonia thank you yes uh this statement
is um submitted by uh miss kate jennings
from religion not
on behalf of the applicants the planning
officer acknowledges
that the site is previously developed
land and within the green belt the
partial or complete
redevelopment of this site is not
considered
inappropriate development in the green
belt this is subject to the impact the
development has
on the openness of the green belt
planning officer in his report has
carried out his own assessment of visual
impact but makes no reference to the
landscape
and visual impact assessment report
prepared by collington winter limited
which accompanied this application the
conclusion
in the report submitted states the site
assessment predominantly found that
when viewed from up to two kilometers
the development
making use of the former poultry shed
footprint
will constitute a minor component of the
wider landscape view
and may not be immediately apparent to
the casual observer
the mature woodland and vegetation which
surrounds little stanbridge hall
will enclose the new units and will
naturally filter views
the key characteristics of the majority
of views
will be neither weakened or strengthened
by the proposals
and there will be no deterioration or
improvement in this view
it is considered therefore that the
redevelopment of this site is
appropriate development in the greenbelt
and the visual impact of this
development is negligible in the white
wider landscape the applicants have
stressed throughout that they're happy
to carry out significant landscaping
on land adjacent to this proposal the
planning officer raises the issue of
encroachment of
the redevelopment into arable land to
the rear
and thus not all of the site is
considered previously developed land
the extension into the land to the rear
is required
to provide the attractive layout for
these units and accommodate the required
parking
it is considered that the overall
economic benefit of this
proposal amounts to very special
circumstances
which would justify the loss of a small
area
of arable land national and local
planning policy supports economic growth
the council's own economic land study
update
highlights the shortfall of growth grow
on office space within the district
and this is especially pronounced in the
rochford area
workspace that is present in the
district is generally
in low supply and the quality of that
supply
is very low this proposal
provides high quality office space in an
attractive setting
which will draw business to the area it
is considered the economic benefit
amounts to very special circumstances
it is also important to note that not
one objection has been received to this
proposal
essex highways essex said the built
heritage and conservation team
the arboricultural officer have all
reviewed this proposal
and have no objection the parish council
supports this proposal
as does rochefort's economic development
officer
no comments have been received by any
members of the public
it is considered that this proposal
offers an
exceptionally high quality design of
small grow on space
which will support the economy in the
rochford area
and we would urge you to support this
proposal
thank you um kemciano
i'm going to let you speak first on this
one
prior to you uh departing
thank you thank you chairman
uh councillors and uh and officers
um the planning officer acknowledges
that this
side has previously developed land and
within the green belt
the partial or complete redevelopment of
this site is not considered
inappropriate development in green belt
society is already in commercial use
but the units provided are of poor
quality
and need rebuilding to provide modern
commercial space
the buildings are currently asbestos low
level buildings the proposal reduces the
footprint
of the buildings from the four to three
and whilst the floor area is smaller the
volume has increased to meet the quality
of the workspace
demanded natural
and local planning policy supports
economic growth
the council's own economic land study
update highlights the shortfall of
growth
on office space within the district and
this especially
pronounces pronounced in the uh
rochford area the city sitting on this
development
offers the smaller businesses in the
eastern rural area
of the district accessible workspace
whilst the airport business park has had
outlined permission since 2015
there is no evidence that development is
moving forward
to supply this economic space in the
short to medium term
this proposal provides high quality
office space
in attractive setting which will draw
business to the area
it is considered the economic benefit
amounts to very special circumstances
which will justify the loss of a small
area of horrible land
to the rear of the site as noted by the
applicant
not one objection has been received to
this proposal
and support for this proposal has
expressed by
both stanbridge parish council and
the rockford economic development
officer
the visual impact was assessed in the
lvii
sorry lvia submitted with the proposal
significant landscape escaping has been
offered by the applicant
and can be considered conditioned to
ensure there is enhancement to this site
i would support this proposal and urge
you to consider the overall benefit
offered by the proposal to the economic
of rochefort
and the wider district thank you
chairman
thank you
um we're just waiting while
can't slow our nose right it's gone
um counselor mrs may uh
counselor mrs mason you've indicated
thank you mr chairman yes you're correct
i did well
i've read this report through a couple
of times so i don't intend to go over
the same thing at things that the
officers
has been very expensive on actually
but i just want to draw attention to a
couple of concerns
um b8 storage and distribution
warehousing and i believe open air
storage
so the best of my knowledge there's no
restriction on this uh b8
is v8 it's not in subcategories
so we could for example have a major uh
supermarket using it in the future
we could have a delivery sales the the
point that i'm making here is the amount
of traffic
would be unmeasurable and unknown
so the concern that stanbridge parish
council
raised about the traffic i think is a
fair one
um limiting the speed is
not within our remit and i can
understand their concern
having said that it's also the volume of
traffic which would be totally unknown
slightly concerned and i'd like the
office that if
you could assist me on this um on the b1
light industry i thought that was that
um
in a residential area we're talking
about ingredient belt
um i don't know if the c i don't know
the significance of the b1 i think it
was c
um it's a minor point anyways but if
clarification also the parking from
what i can see and again it's not clear
from the
information i have but it would appear
that the parking is in greenbelt
which i would think is totally
inappropriate so
i would be inclined to support the
officer's report for refusal
in this instance but i would like to
push on those two points
thank you thank you our cancer steptoe
we'll come back to the various questions
we'll round them up at the end
thank you chairman could i ask the
officer to put the first picture she put
up on the existing buildings please
oh
there you go sorry i think it must be in
the the second picture where it showed
uh across the building it showed some
other buildings in the background
sorry i i thought it was the first
picture
yes that's the one um that building to
the rear of the um
existing um buildings to the front of
the picture
in comparison to the proposed
development
uh is it higher than that existing
building
i would question whether that building
itself in the background there
actually establishes a local height
the other question i had was with
regards to the
uh the building that encroaches slightly
into
the um green belt access
if that was moved closer to the central
building and the entrance the
the the drive entrance was put on the
other side so that was in the green belt
would have that have been acceptable
from from a green belt point of view
two questions i had okay thank you
councillor gooding
thank you chair um
in 8.1 um paragraph 12
it says none of the trees i was a bit
concerned about the trees the existing
trees
um on the one of the officers
photos where the four trees lined up
uh are you able to bring that up katie
it states that they needn't be removed
and
a condition that these mature trees
remain
those trees there and the other point
um was the fact that the the office has
already pointed out
the planning application in 2018
uh was agreed and would support the
economic development
um therefore the
the impact on the green belt would be
harmful
at this current development so
that that would concern me somewhat
those two points
thank you council hawkway
thank you chairman um yes i think this
might be um an example where uh
the uh the applicant is trying to uh
be overly ambitious with um with his
proposal
um and uh trying to uh
probably uh for his own interest quite
rightly trying to maximize
the uh the development and the footprint
but unfortunately
um we have to take into consideration
its impact on the green belt and i think
um the building that encroaches onto
outside of the existing footprint is a
concern and
also the height of the buildings um
does have uh an impact um
i think if if it was
less ambitious um the um
the aspect of uh in improving
uh this type of
facility for businesses would probably
be
it would be acceptable but there has
been an issue raised about
um the one of the the uses being
proposed for storage which means it is
open to the uh not for small business
that could be used by um companies
which large companies wishing to uh make
use of uh
storage and i think that probably is is
another matter of concern as well
thank you okay thank you councillor
williams
uh thank you chairman my main concern
with this application is the fact that
um we can't control the amount or the
the size of the vehicles using this site
it the the the lane that leads up to it
is called little stone bridge hall lane
i believe
um it's quite a long narrow road leading
off of stanbridge road
traffic that actually comes from the
wallacy area
from the wharf has to use braves lane
there is no way that vehicles
could use braced lane to to attend this
site so
in this case i couldn't possibly support
this application
thank you thank you councillor mr shaw
thank you chairman um the developer said
there's no objections which
it probably isn't but if you look at
8.1.16
item 63 essex police did reference
that there was no security submitted
within the application
and they advised the developers to make
direct contact in view to discuss
crime prevention through our
environmental design
now they have they haven't mentioned
whether that was taken place or
um so i've got a concern with that and
also a
question to katie have we got um
an overview of the sizing of the new
um proposed development
over the the old ones so we've got a
view of the
the size the new sizing okay
thank you council stanley
thank you chairman um if every
if everyone on the committee looks at
the structure of those buildings it's
called essex
cladding um it's done it's got weather
balled into it in fact those
properties all those sheds probably were
once
hand coops and uh for for breeding
chickens or getting the eggs
they're very old i know um but
nevertheless the
new design shall i say is twice the
height so that will be a second floor in
there
which would occupy office space uh
for the for those that wish to use it
uh where they would put the goods on the
ground floor and office space
on the first floor um
that would with with the parking area
as well this would exceed well
it just would exceed everything i mean
you've got to understand that there's a
lot of
diesel oil petrol and whatever you're
coming off of that area
so it's it will be contaminated ground
to start with unless there is some cause
of
re siphoning or
or uh filtering of that area
um i think that just costs uh that the
officers have brought
to us uh is correct and i shall
be supporting this application thank you
cancer fd
thank you chairman um been no objections
by the neighbours
we gave permission in 2018 for this to
be
um used as light industrial and we
expect them to use
chicken sheds for light industrial so
maybe they should have proper modern
buildings to actually do
what we've given permission to do for um
so i would actually support this
application
just to be different thank you thank you
chairman
um katie can i ask you to just come back
uh
before we we vote on the various issues
that have been raised uh i'm sure you've
probably been keeping notes around
beware
be b1 parking height be the existing
building the trees
um the overview yeah
um i'll just share my screen with you i
won't share my screen just yet actually
um on the um b1c light industrial
definition of uses that would go into
that category are
any industrial process which wouldn't
have which would
without detriment to amenity by way of
noise vibration smell fumes etc
so the difference between light
industrial b1c is proposed
and b2 general industrial is to do with
the
the nature of the impacts and effects of
those uses
so you're looking at industrial
processes without detriment to emergency
we had then a question about the
existing buildings that are
within the wider site that are higher
and i don't i'm afraid
have the height of those to hand
looking at those um plans the existing
buildings are
going to over double in height and they
will look ab about double
so i think you're looking at the
proposed buildings being approximately
the height of those
much larger buildings that are in the
wider site
but i don't have accurate figures for
you in terms of
whether those buildings then make this
acceptable in greenbelt terms i would
suggest it does not
the assessment in terms of the green
belt and openness has to take account
the existing buildings on the site
versus proposed buildings
on the application site and what is
surrounding
um has an impact in terms of the
character of the area but in the
greenbelt openness terms
we're assessing the existing buildings
on the site versus
um the proposed um there was then a
comment about well if we move the
northernmost building
um within the previously developed area
would it be acceptable in greenbelt
terms
and i would suggest not because it's not
just the fact that these
one of the buildings would be outside of
the previously developed area
the proposed buildings are quite
significantly greater in height
and overall volume than the existing
which is also the green belt assessment
that rochford's policy requires us to
make and national policy does too
i will share my screen now though
because one of the
questions went to did we have a
comparison plan
in terms of the elevations and we do so
at the top of the plan you can see it
says south west elevation
so i'll just move that down a little um
so this with the little um up
stands on the roof this is the existing
and then this is the one of the proposed
buildings you'll see the ridge heights
um over double and then at the
if you come around to the northwest
elevation this is the line of the
existing
and then these the red lines are the
proposed
um
i think as they understand it let me
just go back to the
existing we had a question about trees
i'm just going to take you to the
i think that might be the best one
so my understanding is that the proposal
um the existing trees
that are on this point here would be
removed
and that's part of the proposal but then
um
other trees would be planted that's the
applicant's
um submission um to compensate for the
loss
i think what you can see on the existing
site layout plan
is this area that my cursor is
highlighting here
where those existing mature trees are
positioned
and then over on this side you can see
that some of these buildings are pushed
um further over and towards that
boundary
okay i think
that i think that was it yeah
um okay if you could unsure
um cancer steptoes just indicate i think
i'll just let cancer step
steptoe uh make his point but i think um
members have gained enough information
to make a decision on
on this one so council steptoe yeah
thank you chairman um i think with
agricultural buildings
it's a bit of anomaly it is existing
buildings that
are uh chicken shits and uh you know i
spent my
youth living on a farm with chicken
seeds so i know exactly what they are
um technically they're unusual at the
moment we've already agreed that
there is an economic benefit for making
better use of this particular site
it's interesting and i'm sure officers
will correct me if i'm wrong on this
particular point
that if the uh the land owner or the
farmer
wish to actually replace those buildings
with an ordinary barn or a cattle shed
they wouldn't necessarily require
planning permission and they could build
almost to the exit a
predetermined height of a normal cattle
shed
and i've seen those buildings going up
in my own particular ward
on a number of occasions so it's a bit
of a peculiarity that um
we would have to agree to that but we
are
sort of holding back the development
here of
a potential economic development site so
the chairman
i i'm afraid i can't support the refusal
um to that particular point and
to the point where i would move
acceptance of the um
application
i'd like to second that chairman right
okay
um councillor steptoe i've got to
um ask you to state
your very special circumstances
that mean that this uh this would be
approved if it
for absolute clarity please two two main
reasons chairman
one is it brings unusable buildings
into use and the economic benefits
from that uh from from that um
development okay right
okay then um i think
given the nature of what we've discussed
there would be a
if this were supported by members there
would be
a wide series of conditions
um katie could you
just um say a few words on the nature of
what those conditions would be
or if you'd be happy to
add the the detail of those
i'm afraid what i don't have is is a
list of or even the heads of all of the
conditions that would be necessary that
we would seek to put on um
but um members could if
if they wanted to sort of entrust that
to officers to put on the conditions
that would be reasonably necessary and
serve all the
um meet all the all the tests cancer
with that uh would you be happy with
that in your moment
yeah chairman there are a couple of
conditions that uh listening to other
members that i would perhaps suggest
he's
picked up uh by the officers one is
um a system to mitigate any um
runoff from that particular site
particularly as somebody mentioned about
vehicles
parking there where um there's going to
be muck and stuff
off the vehicles and perhaps in one
condition
and i think i'm right in saying the
access road is actually a private road
the little working hall lane i think
that somebody will correct me from wrong
uh that perhaps a condition should be
looked to make
the the bell mouth of that slightly uh
better
in terms of traffic uh integration into
the uh
into the access road okay you're happy
to continue
seconding that cancer fd yes chairman
okay so members we have a motion
for refusal uh sorry sorry for
approval with the very special
circumstances that
cancerceptor has stated um
can i briefly uh on a point of audience
um
well if you just hold on one sec um
there would be a series of standard
conditions that officers
would put in plus um
condition to two specific ones with
regard to the points that council
steptoes
just just made about runoff and the
nature of the private road so that will
that will be in a moment
the motion that we're uh voting on
councillor hookway you said you had a
point of order yes it was just something
in relation to
what uh cancer steptoes uh said which um
i don't think was um quite quite uh
accurate so
it may influence um some members sort of
thinking
it's just that uh he stated that um
uh because these were were exist the
buildings as existed
are agricultural uh or were were used
for agricultural but
um as as in the report you stated that
they were given a change of use and they
know
now no longer agricultural buildings
because they've been given a change of
view so
if um farmer decided to erect a barn or
something like that
that actually wouldn't necessarily be
allowed that would have to go through
planning to
change its use back to agricultural so
um
these these buildings have already
been given a change in use um it's just
their
the proposal is to demolish them and
erect something
much more substantial which is what the
concerns are of a number of members
yeah okay would you like to just say
anything on that or are you content
if i could just say something um i would
say that
national greenbelt policy and rochford's
own greenbelt policy
clearly differentiates between buildings
um being appropriate for agricultural
use
in the greenbelt which they often are
um and buildings that are for commercial
purposes
so that's the difference and the the
application here
is on previously developed land the
council's previously developed
um land policy is clear um
that those buildings would be
inappropriate and you'd need very
special circumstances which is what
councillor steptoe has talked to i would
though talking about conditions
guard against um we need to make sure
that all conditions would meet the
required tests
and my concern at the moment with um
the one to do with an access is that i'm
not entirely
certain what and where where we're
trying to achieve something
and what we're trying to achieve and
whether it would meet all those five
tests
so i'm happy to leave it that we can
look into those things
um but what i can't guarantee to you is
that we would draw a conclusion that we
could put that those conditions on
yeah nodding his head in agreement yeah
chairman perhaps i can uh clarify a
little bit uh the perhaps that we
suggest to the applicant that he
considers
improvements to the bell mouth of the
access worker
okay uh cancer stanley i don't want to
muddy the waters now we know exactly
where we stand
i don't want to muddy the waters either
chairman
all i've got to say is that this was put
together by the officer
andy we're talking about green belt
we're not talking about accessor road
or anything else this is old green belt
it is not
it is not in our policy and it's and
it's against the
uh uh the green belt policy so
in effect that's what we're voting on
and not whether it is substantial for
more industrial use and all the rest of
it thank you
um you momentarily indicated councillor
williams
thank you um council sandy uh my
point i was going to make thank you
we're moving to the votes now
so the vote is whether we approve
this um with this as mentioned with
special circumstances
and the approach to conditions that
we've outlined so
um if you'd indicate whether you'd like
a recorded vote and
which way you would like to go
councillor fd
uh no he called he votes and i'd like to
approve this with special circumstances
thank you
councillor gooding no recorded vote
and refuse the application thank you
chair
against the approval
okay just for clarity councillor gooding
we're not voting for refusal
we're just voting on whether we approve
or not i don't approve
right okay thank you councillor hawkway
um no recorded vote
and uh against the approval thank you
councillor mrs mason thank you mr
chairman
no recorded vote and against
refusal thank you councillor mrs shaw
no record devoting abstain
counsel mr shaw no report recorded vote
against approval uh
myself no recorded vote against
council stanley
no recorded vote and against cancer
steptoe
no recorded vote and four
councillor williams no recorded vote and
against thank you
councillor wilson no recorded vote and
against
thank you that is lost
one two three four five six seven eight
two so we'll move straight on to the
uh motion for refusal that's printed on
eight point one point two oh
counselor fd there so they
just for clarity everyone's clarity we
are voting
for the refusal or against the refusal
cancer fd no recording vote and
rob stein thank you councillor gooding
no recorded vote and for the refusal
thank you
councillor hawkway no recorded vote
and uh for the refusal thank you
councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and for
refusal thank you councillor mr shaw
no record you vote and abstain
mr shaw no recording vote for refusal
the south no recorded vote for refusal
councillor stanley
no recorded vote and for the refusal
council no recorded vote
and against the refusal thank you
councillor williams
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
for the refusal thank you
councillor williams that's what you just
said that was me
thank you chairman uh no recorded vote
aimed for the refusal
thank you
eight to one to abstentions that item
is refused that at
9 38 concludes the meeting
thank you very much members meeting
class thank you chairman thank you
officers
tonight thank you